I have an emergency surgery to perform
in Baltimore I'll fly wherever I attic
tonight to get there for tomorrow
morning can you help me sir I think we
may have the same problem I have an idea
so what's rush I'm getting married
tomorrow Oh congratulations
no no it's we're not we just met what
circuit Idaho medical conference I'm a
journalist I've been explaining the
questions
[Music]
[Music]
anyway
Hallet you look at me you really hurt
your leg the phone smashed my phone has
no signal and we're pretty high up on
the mountain if we stay here we're safe
if we leave search and rescue are less
likely to find us look I don't want to
die up here because you're too scared to
take a risk
someone's looking for us pilot in files
lightly nobody knows where we are
we're always got me and you we can go
three weeks without food three days
without water and three hours without
shelter
we might die together I don't even know
you
[Music]
we're going to die
for today
nice
[Music]
[Music]